[Musique]
nous sommes le jeudi 15 décembre 2016
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités et
pour débuter je vous propose de revenir
sur le nouveau dispositif de financement
participatif qui a été lancé par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et sky invest c'était hier soir
mercredi que s'est déroulé ce lancement
cette plateforme de crowdfunding va
permettre aux entrepreneurs dès à
présent de booster leur développement
écouté il fouchet c'est l'un des
responsables du dispositif
et c'est au micro d'haussmann vendeurs
des bons jours suivre ce genre bonsoir
c'est vrai alors ce projet sky invest ça
vous tient à coeur j'ai l'impression
pourquoi parce que d'abord je suis
entrepreneur dans l'âme et que j'aime ce
territoire et les entreprises du
territoire les habitants du territoire
et que tout ce que l'on peut faire pour
faciliter la croissance des entreprises
bay faut essayer de le faire
on avait déjà des outils il en manquait
encore on va trouver et mis en place ces
petites financement participatif
c'est vrai que j'en suis assez heureux
c'est une demande des entreprises j'ai
l'impression que le crowdfunding en
france encore à son balbutiement
le crowdfunding le financement
participatif en étant c'est vrai le
financement participatif évidemment
c'est à peu près de 100 millions d'euros
quand il ya 900 milliards d'euros
d'encours de financement bancaire donc
on a encore de la marge de progression
mais il ya un vrai engouement pour ce
dispositif et en plus ça présente
l'avantagé de donner une réalité
territoriale
en fait mon n'est pas sûr que les
investisseurs viennent que dans saint
quentin et j'espère même qui viendront
de très loin ce qui ce bang bang
oui soyons modèle core avoir déjà
démarré dès ce soir mais mais mais dès
ce soir j'ai constaté qu'ils avaient
un certain engouement donc il ya une
réalité territoriale des entreprises de
saint quentin des habitants de saint
quentin des avancées des investisseurs
saint quentinois
je pense que ça peut marcher à 51 ça va
être un outil en plus pour les
entrepreneurs de wade parce que
aujourd'hui on avait on a un outil qui
est la plateforme initiative saint
quentin qui consentent des prêts
d'honneur à dire oui aux entrepreneurs
soit qui démarre sottise développe soit
qui veulent reprendre une entreprise
mais notre financement est limitée par
rapport à l'organisation même à au
maximum une centaine de milliers d'euros
donc au dessus de 100 mille euros on
n'avait pas d'outils disponibles
bien sûr il ya les banques mais on
n'avait pas d'outil local disponible
donc on a cherché et en fait aujourd'hui
avec cette plateforme de financement
participatif soit sous forme de prêt
soit sous forme de participation au
capital
on peut aller de 100 mille euros jusqu'à
un million d'euros
peut-être plus quel type d'entreprise on
peut trouver sur 7
plateforme quel type d'entreprise on va
trouver sur cette plateforme
et aussi comment elles sont choisies
c'est tout type d'entreprise 50 interdit
novation mais l'innovation dans l'esprit
généralement admise c'est de
l'innovation technologique mais pas que
vous pouvez être innovant dans le
commerce ou pas est innovant dans le
service vous pouvez ty neuf ans dans
tous les domaines donc la plateforme
elle est ouverte à tous les types
d'activités simplement le dossier sera
présenté à un comité d'audit et on fera
ce qu'on appelle des diots diligence
dans le jardin dans le jargon c'est à
dire qu'on va regarder si ce qui est
expliqué vraies perspectives sont
réalistes et
donc non il faudra quand même
sérieusement présenter patte blanche
avant de pouvoir être financier qui est
très bien mais pour finir qu'est-ce que
vous souhaiter à cette plateforme
saint-quentinoise je pense finir je
souhaite que tout simplement là on vient
de finir l'inauguration j'ai déjà trois
personnes qui sont venues me voir en me
disant j'ai sûrement deux projets à vous
présenter c'est plutôt satisfaisant donc
ce que je souhaite c'est que on est un
nombre significatif de projets dans
l'année qui vient 2017 si on pouvait en
avoir 10 12 à financer parce que
l'important c'est d'avoir des
entreprises à financer
je pense que des investisseurs ce sera
relativement plus simple donc j'espère
pour la plateforme est pour ça qu
anthony mais qu'on trouve une dizaine
d'entreprises à financer dès l'année
prochaine et pourquoi pas le nouveau
google et pourquoi pas le nouveau google
puisque dans ce cas youtube il ya
peut-être le google de demain
on croise les doigts merci à vous
[Musique]
nous changeons d'univers à présent pour
celui du 7e art actuellement à la fiche
de main tout commence une comédie
dramatique dans lequel dans laquelle
nous retrouvons omar sy l'yvelinois et
comme souvent il a profité de son retour
de son exil à los angeles où il réside
désormais pour venir présenter le film
au public de saint quentin en yvelines
mickey la limite d'euros la rencontrer à
cette occasion le comédien était aussi
accompagné de la jeune révélation de ce
film elle n'a que 12 ans son nom gloria
colston nous sommes à l'ugc de
saint-quentin ligne pour l'avant
première du film j'ai recommencé
nous sommes à l'ugc de saint quentin en
yvelines pour l'avant première du film
demain tout commence alors dans ce long
métrage qui sortira sur les écrans donc
ce mercredi 7 décembre nous aurons
libinois omar sy qui a grandi à quelques
kilomètres de l'ugc de saint quentin en
yvelines
omar je me trompe pas oui c'est exact
mais renseignez vous êtes bien renseigné
usines et j'ai grandi à trappes à côté
oui de saint quentin en yvelines
voilà même si désormais vous vivez à los
angeles on l'a vu à quelques instants
pour l'avant première le public
trappistes vous suit avec attention oui
oui j'en reviens je reviens souvent ici
à skywest avec le film est vrai que
j'ai la chance d'avoir des salles
toujours bien pleines avec un public qui
me réservent un superbe accueil à chaque
fois et je suis très reconnaissant et
vous êtes également accompagné de gloria
dans le gloria qu'olson ces micro voilà
bonsoir bonsoir gloria ouais alors
qu'est ce que ça fait de jouer avec omar
sy massé super voilà il est comme ça il
est est toujours drôle il fait c'est
toujours des blagues et il m'a appris
beaucoup de choses parce que c'est mon
premier film m'a appris en fait parce
qu'entre les scènes on rigole beaucoup
mais par contre quand on travaille en
fait il m'a appris à me concentrer m'a
pris au sérieux en même temps que en
même temps qu hugo et antoine voilà
brisé tant de violence des pop corn en
direct ou indirect
non c'est bon dieu alès samedi cité omar
with big à gloria justement les lecteurs
si là parce qu'en fait c'est toi que
stressé bah oui tu es stressé pourquoi
qu'est ce qui va ça c'est pas du direct
non ce match direct tu vas monter c'est
ça c'est balic pas enlever toutes les
fautes a bafouillé notre aval a
exactement une fois tu arrivais pas dire
skywest voilà redit skywest kg s'est
fait mal à la gloria on en parlait
quelques instants les commandes gloria
du coup que l'oréal est superbe elle est
comme ça là comme tu vois là elle est
très laid mignonne elle c'est une bonne
actrice
elle est très concentré elle apprend
très vite et les elle est très
surprenante mais des gens qui vont voir
le film dont le vin comprendre très vite
moi
à
[Musique]
on parlait de ce film omar depuis tout à
l'heure
opening thériault pour le film et le
talent voilà le film justement au niveau
au niveau du scénario
en fait je fais ça j'ai un bout de pop
corn qu'est qu'on se donne alors ce
scénario du coup et il vous a plu tout
de suite dès que vous l'avez lu way très
drôle tout de suite tout de suite tout
pour faire tous les éléments pour avoir
une très bonne comédie même temps les
éléments pour avoir un bon vélo un beau
un bon moyen de passer de l'un à l'autre
comme ça et après et après avec avec la
mise en scène de dugourd pour avoir le
bon équilibre entre les deux je crois
que c'était ça qui valait heureusement
qu'on a eu le goût pour promettre 100
places et je crois qu'on a un film qui a
un bon équilibre de tout ça en fait d'un
film qui mêle à la fois le rire et
l'émotion un peu roller coaster on nous
a dit souvent donc j'aime bien ça met un
peu c'est ça ouais c'est un peu ça parce
qu'elles vivent landes de cleveland
humain parce que gloria vie accrue
demain les venues de cleveland et tu
pose pas de question et surtout quand
comme on est dans les yvelines
ça me gêne je crois qu'on lui réserve un
accueil digne de ce nom digne de ce nom
parce que sinon tu fout la honte
loria non sarah lauria oui du coup ce
film toi tu l'a ressenti comme ans du
début jusqu'à la fin
tu vas ressenti comme en bas c'est un
peu compliqué de le dire comme ça on
directement train direct voilà c'est ça
non mais en fait au début j'avais en
fait hugo il m'a dit en gros l'histoire
j'ai bulls et l'agneau les scénarios
sebha plus au sénat blouet sénat blot
avait pourtant tout il serait tout est
en fait il me l'a dit après avoir lu le
sénat blot après voilà j'ai des émotions
qui vont pâtir
voilà les gloriettes adieu alors une
grande carrière selon jana inch'allah
mais voilà c'est son premier film je
trouve qu'elle démarre très bien après
il ya évidemment encore des choses à
apprendre encore des choses à faire
il y aura aussi des choix mais en tout
cas à la halle a tout ce qu'il faut pour
pour pour se lancer
je vous encourage vivement même à
continuer mais ça je lui ai déjà dit et
mais voilà c'est c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas assez pas sans travail et sans
ça ce sera pas les doigts dans le nez
mais comme je sais que c'est déjà une
grande bosseuse
je m'inquiète pas beaucoup après je suis
plutôt superstitieux donc je vais pas
envie non plus de trop dire parce que je
voudrais pas lui porter leur ai donc que
je remets 1,5 pour te protéger mon
enfant
dernière question mars il ya un film qui
va sortir à bientôt sur les écrans
star wars rogue one parce que vous êtes
un fan de star wars tu te fous de ma
gueule tu es en train de te de ma
gueule non valides oui le film de demain
tout comme ans qui sera barrée à
l'affichage film veut que je fasse de la
promo pour star wars et au pape ou star
wars
j'ai un bébé sur les bras compass amer
j'ai tout perdu mon portefeuille j'ai
plus de couches et une bleue à vous
parler français ouais ça m'arrive vous
allez me sauver la vie bazire on n'est
pas à peu près là c'est pas fou s'il
faut changer l'âge il ya mes coordonnées
pro et ça c'est perso non je te parlerai
pas de star wars était malade star wars
vannes où vonn l'avait en même temps que
nous à la fiche je peux faire de la
promo pour star wars
non papa pour qu'est ce que tu vaux le
film qu'est ce que tu veux sans est ce
que ça pourrait vous intéresser un jour
star wars star donc déjà tourné les 19,1
l'épisode 9 bien sûr ça m'intéresse mais
même le pas proposé ne proposeront pas
je pense c'est pas dans vos objectifs
vous connaissez très bien réalisateur
oui mais on ne fait pas ça se passe pas
comme ça tu sais c'est le réalisateur
qui choisit en fait on peut même si
c'est notre copain en appel tu peux me
donner un rôle j'ai vu je ferais pas ça
comme on va terminer à l'entretien là
dessus vous d'avis que cinq minutes
donc on va terminer là dessus voilà
alors demain tout commencera ce mercredi
7 décembre sur les écrans français
bravo tu abuses le téton c'était ton
baptême stern hommage à ces mêmes voix
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
ce soir prochaine édition ce sera à
lundi très bon week end les replays
avoir dès à présent sur notre site
internet
[Musique]